légaliser les drogues douces trouve
l'idée stupéfiante où elle trouve
stupéfiant que cela n'ait pas encore été
fait muriel ne l'ont verrièle de l'on
pense que c'est stupéfiant d'être
stupéfait la conception du luxe
c'est comme les plombiers style il ou
elle sait comment elle va mal mais ça va
mais là je peux pas arriver là bas ça va
mais là je n'ai pas voulu mettre cette
semaine ça pour faire du social
elle augmenterait les salaires ou elle
réduit le temps de travail
muriel robin saison mais c'est très
décevant bref elle va alors muriel robin
[Rires]
qu'est ce qu'elle en pense alors quand
le temps le travail pour faire du social
est très chaud content d'être là alors
pour taper dafri mail préféré rouler
sans bornes en ferrari avec un boudin ou
du bord en tracteur avec un top canon
muriel robin préféré rouler dans une
ferrari avec un top canon et mélangent à
lui mais je veux pas voir l'une ou
l'autre ça ne va pas du tout en tant que
star ce qu'elle supporte le moins c'est
être l'objet de toutes les conversations
ou être l'objet d'aucune barbade
supporte pas de ne pas être un sujet de
conversation mais c'est ok évidemment je
sais pas je n'ose même pas l'imaginer
elle commence à bien comprendre
ouais ça peut lancer ou d'arrêter de
faire des télécoms ça donc je pose alors
lui diront que c'est plus lent qu'à tel
le sentiment d'avoir le plus souvent
raté sa chance d'être un ou d occasion
de la fermer
je crois que muriel lou romain louvre ça
c'est toujours pour quelque chose à
votre question venir rebelles ne rate
jamais tractopelle a appris ce qu'il
faut c'est parce que la partie est monté
sur faut calmer le jeu prend pas ce
commerce du sexe est ce qu'elle est pour
la réouverture des maisons closes ou
pour la fermeture des boîtes à partys
non vraiment bien pense que les boîte à
partouze
c'est très agréable à vivre sa vie si
c'est très drôle il adore dire des mots
que je dis pas souvent non pense que la
femme n'ont que les boîte à partouze je
me souviens déjà vu la question qu'il
faut en tout cas les maisons closes
d'accord photo t'ouvrir mais alors ma
pense qu'il faut ouvrir vers le bas est
elle même très ouvert et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux